- Je suis psychologue, je suis
d'origine québécoise.
- Je suis née au Vietnam
et je suis au Québec depuis une
trentaine d'années.
- Moi je suis originaire
de la France.
- Une fois par semaine, les
professionnels de la Clinique
pédiatrique transculturelle de
l'Hôpital Maisonneuve Rosemont,
entourent enfants et parents.
- Je m'appelle Lyly Huynh,
je suis étudiante en médecin
- Ici, les origines et la
culture sont aussi importantes
que sont les signes vitaux
d'un patient à l'urgence.
TINH-NHAN LUONG, pédiatre, dir.t
- On n'est pas dans les soins
physiques, on est dans
les problèmes de santé mentale
ou psychosociaux vraiment plus
compliqués.
- Ce sont souvent des familles
qui ont un parcours migratoire
vraiment complexe, avec
des traumatismes, avec souvent
des moments de séparation.
C'est souvent toute la famille
qui a besoin d'aide,
c'est pas seulement l'enfant.
- Les filles d'Ana Walteros
et de Fabio Gonzales ont été
référées à la clinique
transculturelle pour des
troubles anxieux et une perte
de poids inquiétante chez l'une
des jumelles de 7 ans.
D'origine colombienne,
la famille a vécu un parcours
sant. Ils sont arrivés
comme réfugiés au Québec,
il y a 3 ans.
- Nous ss ici
au Canada comme réfugiés.
- Après un an de consultation,
les parents estiment que cette
équipe multidisciplinaire
et multi-ethnique a changé
leur vie.
La clinique a été créée
au tournant des 0
pour intervenir avec
une meilleure compréhension
du bagage culturel.
- Il peut y avoir aussi
des différences culturelles que
les intervenants ou les médecins
ne réussissent pas à comprendre.
Parce que l'on ne peut pas
connaître toutes les cultures.
Et il y a aussi
des croyances, que ce soit
religieuses ou mystiques,
qui peuvent être antes
pour les intervenants.
Par exemple un enfant qui a un
diagnostent
nous dit : "Non je pense que
quelqu'un lui a envoyer un
mauvais audrait faire
tel ou tel traitement au pays
d'origine".
- L'interprète est membre à part
entière de l'équipe
d'intervenants.
- Même si la famille parle
francais ou anglais, parce que
nous on dit que les choses du
coeur se disent plus facilement
dans une langue maternelle
que dans une langue secondaire.
- Les références pour cette
clinique très particulière
ne cessent d'affluer.
- On a assez de ressources
seulement pour fonctionner unepn
aurait du travail pour plus
que ça. On peut se demander,
c'est beaucoup de ressources;
avoir tous ces gens pourune fame
d'un groupe comme ça, c'est
d'apporter différents sens
au problème.
- Je suis né ici à Montréal,
mais mes parents sont d'origine
vietnamienne.
- Et l'on voudrait bien former
plus d'intervenants à cette
l'approche transculturelle
dans le réseau de la santé
ICI Anne-Louise Despatie
Radio-Canada, Montréal